alors plein de choses à voir plein de
kiosque à visiter au salon du livre
encore une fois cette année un rendez
vous incontournable c'est le kiosque de
la lecture en cadeau et salomé corbo
porte-parole depuis maintenant 50 ce bel
événement est ici pour nous en parler
bonjour pour ceux qui sont moins
familiers que cette initiative en la
résumant rapidement alors c'est tout
simple il ya environ deux cent mille
enfants qui vivent dans des milieux
défavorisés au québec ces enfants là
n'ont pas accès à la littérature pour
diverses raisons
alors l'idée c'est cette année pour
fêter nos vingt et un ces données cent
mille livres neufs à des enfants ce
milieu défavorisé bel objectif mais
comment concrètement comment ça marche
et 5 5,5 et vous suffit d'acheter en
ligne et de venir le déposer dans not
born cette année on a un petit truc plus
sympathique un peu on entend les enfants
des vrais enfants vivraient enfants qui
ont été enregistrées depuis que de
verdure exactement à qui on dit des
envies demande donc vous pouvez venir
entendre les demandes des enfants ont
fait des suggestions de lecture mais
vous y allez vraiment de votre envie
personnelle les livres qui vous ont
marqués qui sait 1 et ensuite mais vous
insérez le livre ici tout simplement
vous pouvez remplir une carte postale ou
s'il enfants volés sous employés sous la
presse francis et c'est beaucoup pour le
guillou et ça ce sont donc des livres
neufs qui aboutissent d'aller mettre ces
enfants-là parfois c'est le premier riff
qui tiennent à leur mais souvent c'est
en fait qu'il ramène à la mer exactement
souvent les enfants je suis souvent les
eaux collecte et au pot collecte non à
la collecte suis là tout le temps mais
quand on donne mais lille est souvent
les enfants demandent mais est-ce que je
peux le ramener chez moi je suis pas
obligé de le ramener à la bibliothèque
il est vraiment à moi donc on se rend
compte de l'importance pour ces enfants
là d'avoir un objet qui est en eux un
objet neuf puis un avion ce qui les
amène à découvrir le monde
c'est ça qui est le plus beau le plus
beau le plus noble dans cette initiative
merci beaucoup ça devait derrière la
lecture c'est vraiment important
puis moi ma fille a eu la chance aux
normands de maison il y avait plein de
lait mais c'est pas donné à tous les
enfants puissent quoique avec des livres
on peut peut-être accrocher les enfants
l'école fait que ce soit très important
de le faire